mr. Chaffetz you came in first ballot
fifth place are you gonna stay in the
race or do you think it's time to fold
the cards I'm absolutely staying in I'm
pleased with the result because it means
I'm through to the next round and I've
got the days and the weeks ahead to
continue making my cases some of your
colleagues suggested to me that given
that your Home Secretary they would have
expected you to have a better showing in
the first round what would you say to
that
well it is crowded and I think there's
probably threats and it got more
contestants in this leadership election
than we've ever seen before it does mean
votes are going to get bit I mean
clearly Boris Johnson has done well in
the first round and I think he's you're
almost certain or nailed on to be in the
final two so this is now a battle for
who gets to be with Boris in that file -
you described Boris Johnson is
yesterday's man was that a mistake given
that it looks like he's actually gonna
be tomorrow's prime minister no it's not
a mistake he's just trying to set up her
a choice there we've got an opportunity
here as a party to try and reach out to
more voters because if we look at the
history of the Conservative Party in the
last quarter of a century we've only won
one election and that was only just in
2015 that's the only majority we
achieved and we only get that by having
broad appeal across the country to all
parts of society you've met with Matt
Hancock the health secretary last night
or yesterday to discuss what you should
do did you decide with him that one of
you would pull out the heaps maybe
support you yeah not care again - any
discussions I've had with any other
candidate - it wouldn't be right but it
shouldn't surprise anyone that once
you've had the results of the first
ballot that a lot of the candidates and
their supporters will talk hear the
history of these contests are they are
quite fluid and things do shift so we'll
have to wait and see what happens go on
- brexit then let's just let's just
quickly get your brexit policy I
understand what you're saying about you
think you need to directly negotiate
with the Irish government in order to
try and resolve the back stop which is
the bed blocker of getting some sort of
agreement through but you've also said
that we must leave on October the 31st
what what happens if Parliament tries to
block that which could
look of course look I'm a kid where
Parliament could try that and I've also
said I don't want to see a general
election until we've delivered brexit so
that means I accept it's this Parliament
yeah and I've seen what's been happening
we've all seen yeah and I think the way
through that is to come back with a deal
the Parliament can accept and that's
exactly why I've said that what I would
focus on is the only deal that's got
through Parliament and that is the
withdrawal agreement which changes to
the backstop it has to be October 31st
but I think part of the problem we've
had in in recent times is that there's
been no sort of what I would like a
proper deadline you know if you if
you're if are the EU friends know that
will the deadline can always keep
changing keep changing it doesn't really
focus the minds there and here so I
think you have to have a solo and you
have to focus on it in terms of a No
Deal brexit or absolutely excellent talk
that for us you are historically a
businessman a deal maker you understand
finance better than most people in that
cabinet you also understand the economic
risk don't you of a No Deal brexit that
business might not be ready for or want
on October 31st are you prepared to have
that put onto the British people British
people have voted to leave that we have
to deliver that result without having a
single friend and without continuing to
deal I understand that but you'll but
you're allowing Nigel Farage to box the
Conservative Party in to making it have
to be on October the 31st because he
said anything else as a brexit betrayal
you're prepared to do that
despite what you know could be the
economic fallout for British citizen
well this is not about Nigel Faraj at
all this is about a commitment that we
as conservatives made at the last
general election in 2017 where we said
we would take the UK deal or no deal out
of the EU buy in that case by March I
don't want no deal but if you want to be
Prime Minister in this country you have
to be responsible and you have to
prepare as it could and so I put to you
you want to be Prime Minister and I'm
going to read to you some of the stuff
from a mark said will the most senior
Mandarin in
anin eat paper again but on anodal
brexit warning food prices up 10% police
unable to protect the public direct rule
in ulster the worst recession since 2008
another study commissioned by the
government about what happens if you
have two minutes
delays in dover 17-mile tackle box and
the m20 in gridlock I mean do you want
to be the Prime Minister that puts that
on the British people I've always
accepted there will be charges to No
Deal
but I also do think that we can prepare
much more the Donald Trump visit in that
state dinner which you didn't attend do
you think it was a mistake would you
think it was a conscious decision I'm
not gonna speculate honestly I don't
know I I don't know the reason I did
when I learned that wasn't going my
office did inquire about it and they did
ask and they were told that I wasn't
invited and and I left it they what you
think it's the Queen doesn't like you
all I think it's like anything to do
with the past at all these lists are put
together but of course of course state
dinners but it says the government that
decides especially when it comes to
govern ministers who goes has the
government only though I was right
because number 10 said yesterday that it
was the Queen that takes the decisions
now it's a it's a government position
clearly someone inside number 10 who
decided the Home Secretary should not
come I don't know who that someone is
and I don't know why they made that
decision